it's been over a year and a half since
valorant released a controller agent
which is pretty crazy if you think about
it but things are about to change
because Harbor is almost here
yeah and you're heavy
welcome development Harbor's kit is
unlike any other agent in fact one of
his abilities is able to block bullets
you heard me one of his abilities
literally blocks bullets so let's get
into it
so if you're like me and you've been
playing a lot of valorant lately then
sometimes you need a reminder to touch
grass and speaking of touch grass make
sure to check out the link below for
some of our dope new merch episode 5 act
3 is right around the corner and
yesterday Liz Dimitri and I were lucky
enough to test the new update early and
honestly it was a lot of fun but I know
that most of you are dying to hear about
Harbor Harbor is valorant's fifth
controller agent and he's the first
agent we've seen who hails from India
all of his abilities are water-based and
aesthetically they look pretty sick so
let's start there his sea ability
Cascade sends out a wave that can go
through walls and can be activated again
to stop it any players who walk through
it will be slowed Harbors Q ability Cove
is probably the most interesting it can
be thrown onto the ground to create a
shielding water sphere which takes quite
a few bullets to destroy Harbor's
signature ability called High Tide acts
similar to a phoenix wall but instead
you can curb it through walls and just
like Cascade High Tide slows anyone who
walks through it last but not least
Harper's alts Reckoning summons a geyser
pool to the ground and any enemies
caught in it will be targeted and
concussed it can hit up to three times
so you definitely want to get the hell
out of it as soon as possible so Harbor
is obviously meant to be a controller
but after playing against him yesterday
I think it's safe to say that he sort of
plays like an initiator too the fact
that his abilities can slow and stun and
his smokes are all single use makes him
feel more like a hybrid agent which I'm
perfectly fine with I play [__]
chamber for what it's worth so I can't
say that dude's still a do list in my
eyes but plenty of pros and content
creators have already pointed out that
they don't think Harbor can fulfill the
role of a solo controller region
obviously it's only been a day and
things will change as players learn how
to play with and against him but right
now I agree with what most people are
saying he seems like a niche pick that
will force teams to continue to run a
second controller KO seems like a strong
tool for retakes especially on pistol
rounds because it can take a lot of
shots to break the shield but personally
I think Viper is still stronger because
she can use her utility whenever she has
fuel if Harbor had some type of fuel
mechanic then maybe he'd seem a bit more
appealing to me but again I don't want
to get ahead of myself because we've
literally only seen this guy for a day
overall I think he's a cool agent and we
definitely needed a new controller
option but I'll probably just continue
to lock in chamber and make my
co-workers mod
[Music]
DED
foreign
[Music]
and next I must talk about the most
important part of the game the one thing
that keeps me coming back because I've
just spent way too much money on them
the Skins the new battle pass is
honestly clean for ten dollars you got
some nice skins buddies sprays and what
I always love are the new player cards
good job riot take more of my money ion
2.0 is also on its way so I'm pretty
much another change that's coming next
week is this new UI I think it's pretty
clean overall but I can't click on my
collection without first going back to
the main menu right now so it's kind of
annoying but I'm sure I'll get used to
it I'm excited for this update I've been
playing a ton of old school RuneScape
lately so I'm happy to see something
fresh added to Valerian I think this is
what I and many others need to come back
to the game
is uh
sound good okay
don't tell me what to do Tanner don't
tell me what to do how about that huh
flawless
laughs